Shure: 就 这个地就跟我水土不服
Shure: It's like I'm not acclimatized to this place.
Shure:  哎呀刚才特伤心
Shure: Oh man, I was so sad just now.
Shure:  所有人盯住我
Shure: Everyone was staring at me.
Shure:  完了回去你要跪搓衣板了
Shure: Now you'll have to kneel on the washboard when you get back.
其他人：哎你好这个叫什么呀
Others: Hey, what is this called?
其他人：这叫花棍
Others: This is called a flower stick.
其他人：花棍
Others: Flower stick.
Jake:花棍
Jake: Flower stick.
Lucia: 花棍
Lucia: Flower stick.
Shure: 因为把你手
Shure: Because you gave me...
Shure:  因为把你送我的手串给弄坏了
Shure: Because I broke the bracelet you gave me.
Alice:我能看一下您怎么开始的吗
Alice: Can I see how you start?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
其他人：哦
Others: Oh
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh
Shure:  我能拿下试一下吗
Shure: Can I try it?
其他人：好厉害
Others: That's impressive.
Alice:哦这样起来的
Alice: Oh, so that's how you do it.
Shure: 我试一下啊
Shure: Let me give it a try.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 我肯定可以
Shure: I can definitely do it.
Alice:我能使两个棍弄起来吗
Alice: Can I use two sticks to make it work?
Shure:  你好我我我要试一下谢谢
Shure: Hi, I, I want to try, thanks.
Shure:  哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 太快了
Shure: Too fast.
Shure:  我找到了
Shure: I found it.
Shure: 哎哟哟呦不好意思不好意思
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah!
Jake: 这自怎么自己做的
Jake: How did you make this yourself?
Jake:外边买
Jake: Bought it outside.
Jake:哦也卖
Jake: Oh, they also sell it.
Jake: 要不咱两个扔试试
Jake: How about we both try to throw it?
Shure: 两个肯定不行
Shure: Two definitely won't work.
Jake:两个两个棍
Jake: Two sticks.
Jake: 两个棍容易一点
Jake: Two sticks are easier.
Jake: 耶转起来了
Jake: Yay, it's spinning!
Jake: 就刚刚刚刚那一段
Jake: Just that part, just now.
Jake: 然后就重复剪出来
Jake: Then just repeat and cut it out.
Jake: 重复你就一直转
Jake: Just keep spinning.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈GIF出来了
Jake: Haha, we made a GIF.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake: 够剪了够剪了够剪了
Jake: Enough to cut, enough to cut.
Shure:  成谢谢您大爷
Shure: Done, thank you very much.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Shure:  跟你讲这个地儿就克我
Shure: I'm telling you, this place is cursed for me.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure:  这地儿就不吉利克我你知道吗
Shure: This place is unlucky for me, you know?
Shure:  我刚才跟我女发朋友 发公园的照片吗
Shure: I just sent my girlfriend a photo of the park.
Shure:  她说怎么感觉这儿好熟悉
Shure: She said it looked so familiar.
Shure:  她把之前跟她前男友溜狗的照片
Shure: Then she sent a picture of her walking her dog with her ex-boyfriend.
Shure:  她那个前男友的家好像在这附近
Shure: Turns out her ex-boyfriend lives around here.
Shure:  她说这是不是6号线哪儿哪儿哪儿哪个站哪 个站中间
Shure: She asked if it's somewhere between this or that station on Line 6.
Katrina: 哎呦前男友显灵了
Katrina: Oh wow, her ex-boyfriend's spirit is here.
Shure:  他说没事
Shure: She said it's fine.
Shure:  给你挡灾了
Shure: She'll protect me from disasters.
Shure:  还好有这个事儿顶一下
Shure: Good thing for this situation.
Shure: 不然话就会被骂
Shure: Otherwise, I would have been scolded.
Alice:禁止钓鱼
Alice: No fishing allowed.
Katrina: 这好多鱼啊明明感觉水质不是特别好
Katrina: There are so many fish here even though the water doesn't seem that great.
Katrina: 这是柳絮吧是不是
Katrina: Is this willow fluff?
Shure:  不是就是那些沫沫什么的
Shure: No, it's just some foam or something.
Katrina:  怎么会这么多鱼啊
Katrina: How can there be so many fish?
Katrina:  感觉这水质不是特别好
Katrina: The water doesn't seem that great.
Shure:  水却清则无鱼
Shure: Clear water has no fish.
Shure: 水太清它们就没吃的了吗
Shure: If the water is too clear, they won't have anything to eat?
Katrina:  好厉害啊
Katrina: That's amazing.
Shure:  就是这吧
Shure: Right, it's this one.
Shure: 6号线上这个中间
Shure: In the middle of Line 6.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 北京瀑布
Katrina: The Beijing waterfall.
Shure:  你带了头盔
Shure: You brought a helmet.
Shure:  可是没有插上
Shure: But you didn't plug it in.
Jake: 一会再插
Jake: We'll plug it in later.
Jake: 刚刚其实应该插一下
Jake: Actually, we should've plugged it in earlier.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 他一次只能录25分钟
Jake: It can only record for 25 minutes at a time.
Jake: 我要找到25分钟的那个时间段
Jake: I need to find that 25-minute segment.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 刚刚那段其实挺好的忘了
Jake: That last part was really good, but we forgot.
Lucia: 严谨
Lucia: Meticulous.
Shure:  有些事儿不信不行啊
Shure: Some things you just have to believe.
Shure: 太灵了
Shure: It's so incredible.
Shure:  哦有蛤蟆
Shure: Oh, there's a frog.
Lucia: 我还以为打开方式是晚上我们吃鸡爪子
Lucia: I thought tonight we were going to eat chicken feet.
Jake:是这个意思她给我吃叶子
Jake: That's what I mean, she gave me leaves to eat.
Shure: 刚刚叫了
Shure: Just called.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Shure:  我说我说这里面有蛤蟆刚刚叫了
Shure: I said there was a frog in here that just called.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure:  听到了蟾蜍的叫声
Shure: Heard the sound of a toad.
Shure:  看看有没有稍微践踏一下
Shure: See if there's any slight trampling.
Shure:  没有我听到了
Shure: No, I heard it.
Shure:  蛤蛤蛤蟆听取蛙声一片
Shure: Frog, frog, frog sounds everywhere.
Shure: 哇哇
Shure: Wow, wow.
Katrina: 水至清则无鱼人至贱则无敌
Katrina: If the water is too clear, there are no fish; if a person is too cheap, they are invincible.
Katrina: 谁说的
Katrina: Who said that?
Shure:  这是国宝特工
Shure: It's from National Treasure Agent.
Shure:  是吧你小时候看过吗
Shure: Right? Did you watch it as a kid?
Shure:  然后那个
Shure: And then...
Shure:  不是是那个戴一个眼罩的那个
Shure: No, it's the one with the eye patch.
Katrina: 水至清则无鱼人至贱则无敌
Katrina: If the water is too clear, there are no fish; if a person is too cheap, they are invincible.
Shure:  叫什么贼眉鼠眼
Shure: What's it called, Sneaky Eyes?
Shure:  认贼作父还有什么来着他们四个
Shure: Recognizing a thief as a father, what else was there, the four of them.
Lucia: 我看了好多科幻电影
Lucia: I watched a lot of sci-fi movies.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure:  前面这条是京杭大运河
Shure: In front of us is the Grand Canal.
Jake: 哪一条啊
Jake: Which one?
Tasha:  真的吗前面的这条河
Tasha: Really? This river in front?
Tasha:  我们就可以回家了阿sir
Tasha: We can go home now, officer.
Shure:  对这块
Shure: Yes, right here.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 那你的那个手链在杭州可以能找到
Jake: So can you find your bracelet in Hangzhou?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  你怎么知道我过一段要去杭州
Shure: How did you know I was planning to go to Hangzhou soon?
Jake: 那你去找找
Jake: Then you should look for it.
Shure:  那你看看前面就是京杭大运河
Shure: Look, that's the Grand Canal up ahead.
Shure:  我们在杭州
Shure: We're in Hangzhou.
Shure:  是不是就能捞上来给它
Shure: Can we just fish it up for him?
Shure:  我们是不是又逛回来了
Shure: Did we just walk back here again?
Shure: 听到了吧
Shure: Did you hear that?
Katrina:  听到这个是蛤蟆声
Katrina: I heard, that's the sound of frogs.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina:  我觉得这个黄绿黄绿的树好看
Katrina: I think the yellow-green trees are beautiful.
Katrina:  没见过
Katrina: Never seen them before.
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why?
Katrina:  我从来没有见过
Katrina: I've never seen them before.
Katrina:  这难道是北方特有的吗
Katrina: Are they unique to the north?
Shure: 有可能吧
Shure: Could be.
Katrina:  我们只有石楠花
Katrina: We only have photinia flowers.
Shure:  哈哈那个很臭的是吗
Shure: Haha, those smell really bad, right?
Katrina:  臭的要命
Katrina: They smell awful.
Katrina:  就是想呕
Katrina: They make you want to throw up.
Katrina:  它是那种汗腋下的臭
Katrina: It's the smell of sweaty armpits.
Shure: 我听过它的味道描述
Shure: I've heard descriptions of the smell.
Shure:  是那个的味道吧
Shure: Is it really that smell?
Shure: 可能吧
Shure: Could be.
Shure:  真不了解
Shure: I really don't know.
Shure:  北京就两种鸟基本上喜鹊和乌鸦
Shure: In Beijing, there are basically two types of birds: magpies and crows.
Katrina:  什么你说北京
Katrina: What? You said Beijing?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina:  没见过喜鹊
Katrina: Never seen a magpie.
Shure: 刚刚飞过好几只
Shure: Several just flew by.
Katrina:  当然当然确确实看到很多乌鸦
Katrina: Of course, I have seen a lot of crows.
Katrina:  我当时我有个北邮的好朋友
Katrina: I had a good friend from Beiyou.
Katrina:  早上玩的时候北邮海淀那个校区
Katrina: This morning when I was playing at Beiyou Haidian campus,
Katrina:  那个外面有一棵树
Katrina: there was a tree outside.
Katrina:  然后在那打车
Katrina: Then I was getting a taxi there.
Katrina:  打车我一抬头看全是
Katrina: When I looked up, it was full of...
Katrina:  我说哎好大鸟
Katrina: I said, "Wow, what a big bird!"
Katrina:  这什么然后一抬头树上全是
Katrina: What's this? Then I looked up again, the tree was full of them.
Katrina:  就很恐怖
Katrina: It was really scary.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  在那个晚上
Katrina: That night,
Katrina:  我真的没见过那么大
Katrina: I had never seen such big...
Katrina:  一般南方见的都是那种小麻雀
Katrina: Usually in the south, you only see those small sparrows.
Katrina:  麻雀
Katrina: Sparrows.
Shure:  乌鸦
Shure: Crows.
Shure: 一看就是刚浇完的
Shure: It looks like it was just watered.
Katrina:  什么刚浇
Katrina: Just watered?
Shure: 水
Shure: Water.
Katrina: 这呀
Katrina: This?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 这不土吗
Katrina: Isn't this soil?
Katrina:  中间是什么
Katrina: What's in the middle?
Shure:  中间看像刚浇的吗
Shure: Does the middle look like it was just watered?
Katrina:  你说浇水吗
Katrina: You mean watering?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  什么东西 你在想
Shure: What are you thinking about?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  我不是那样的人
Katrina: I'm not that kind of person.
Shure:  你还重复好几遍
Shure: You repeated it several times.
Katrina:  我一直以为是那个建筑材料的钢呢
Katrina: I always thought it was steel for construction materials.
Shure:  我的天呐
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  数据集
Shure: Data set.
Shure:  不要听这些
Shure: Don't listen to this.
Katrina:  数据集直接紊乱了
Katrina: The data set is completely messed up.
Katrina:  识别不出来
Katrina: It can't recognize it.
Shure:  这两个人说着说着话又说的啊
Shure: These two people are talking nonsense again.
Katrina:  这个公园其实可以往里面钻钻钻钻
Katrina: This park actually allows you to go deep inside.
Shure: 你们好
Shure: Hello.
Shure:  拍一些四个人
Shure: Let's take some photos of the four of us.
Shure:  向我徐徐走过来的样子
Shure: Walking slowly towards me.
Shure:  你好害怕
Shure: You look so scared.
Shure:  你好可怕呀
Shure: You look so terrifying.
Shure:  你这个就是就是就是
Shure: You were just, just, just
Jake: 一棒槌下去是吧
Jake: One hit with a stick, right?
Shure:  一脸严肃
Shure: With a serious face
Shure:  然后架着肩膀就这样走过来
Shure: Then walk over with your shoulders up like this
Shure:  我爬山了哎
Shure: I'm climbing the mountain, hey
Lucia: 不知道是哪几个字有诗意的呢哈哈
Lucia: I wonder which words sound poetic, haha
Jake: 是是是一个华山
Jake: Yes, yes, it's Huashan
Katrina:  丁香
Katrina: Lilac
Jake: 简称华山
Jake: Simply called Huashan
Katrina:  在小学课文上
Katrina: In elementary school textbooks
Jake: 我们在爬华山
Jake: We are climbing Huashan
Katrina:  这不会就是紫丁香吧
Katrina: Isn't this the lilac?
Shure:  啊这就是对但是它已经枯了不香了
Shure: Ah yes, but it's already withered and not fragrant anymore
Katrina:  哇原来长这样
Katrina: Wow, so this is how it looks
Shure:  你走近脱下叹息般的目光丁香般的芬芳
Shure: You walk close, taking off with a sigh, the fragrance of lilac
Katrina:  没见过紫丁香
Katrina: Never seen a lilac
Katrina:  那白的呢
Katrina: How about the white one?
Alice:白丁香
Alice: White lilac
Katrina:  白丁香
Katrina: White lilac
Shure:  （歌声）三九的梅花红了漫山
Shure: (singing) The plum blossoms in the coldest days are red all over the mountain
Katrina:  提问我们现在在什么地方
Katrina: Question, where are we now?
Shure: 我们在
Shure: We are
Shure:  AI会不会以为我们刚刚又回去了
Shure: Will AI think we just went back again?
Shure:  我以为你看到蘑菇了呢
Shure: I thought you saw a mushroom
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes
Shure:  这时候应该
Shure: At this moment
Shure:  不知道这是什么塔
Shure: I don't know what this tower is
Shure:  这是什么塔
Shure: What is this tower?
Katrina: 雷峰塔
Katrina: Leifeng Pagoda
Alice:雷峰塔
Alice: Leifeng Pagoda
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Katrina: 胡说八道张口就来
Katrina: Nonsense, you just say whatever
Jake: 哎咱在哪啊
Jake: Hey, where are we?
Alice:您的位置
Alice: Your location
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where?
Tasha:  我刚刚想买但你们都走远了
Tasha: I wanted to buy it just now, but you all walked too far
其他人：就这售货机里有一个饮料我还挺想买的
Others: There's a drink in this vending machine that I really want to buy
Tasha:  我刚刚看你想买你们都走了
Tasha: I saw you wanted to buy it but you all left
Shure: 哪呢
Shure: Where?
Jake: 哦售货机
Jake: Oh, the vending machine
其他人：下次再遇到我就买
Others: Next time I see it, I'll buy it.
Jake: 好一会转
Jake: Okay, turn for a bit.
Jake: 转到最后的这个地方
Jake: Turn to the very end.
Jake: 然后再多走一段
Jake: And then walk a bit more.
Alice:什么饮料好喝吗
Alice: Is there any good drink?
其他人：我感觉看到挺好喝的
Others: I think it looks pretty good.
Shure:  我只想要瓶水就可以
Shure: I just want a bottle of water.
其他人：对水也可以
Others: Yeah, water is fine too.
Lucia: 自动售货机
Lucia: Vending machine.
Shure:  不想去那你就退掉吧
Shure: If you don't want to go, then cancel it.
Shure:  好多人啊哪 儿人都多估计
Shure: So many people, there are people everywhere I guess.
Lucia: 所以这就是一个公园只不过有一个北关大道把他们俩隔开了
Lucia: So this is a park, but it's separated by Beiguan Avenue.
Shure:  怎么你想退吗
Shure: Do you want to cancel?
Shure:  退的话给你补个差价
Shure: If you cancel, I'll make up the difference for you.
Shure:  你要是心疼的话
Shure: If you're worried about it.
Jake: 我们去买水吧
Jake: Let's go buy water.
Tasha: 刚刚你们没看到我
Tasha: You guys didn't see me just now.
Lucia: 蝴蝶诱捕器
Lucia: Butterfly trap.
Jake: 拿网抓是吧
Jake: You catch it with a net, right?
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我们是在说怎么形容
Lucia: We were talking about how to describe it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 这个是蝴蝶诱捕器
Jake: This is a butterfly trap.
Lucia: 对对对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 你们就过来了是吧
Jake: You guys just came over, right?
Lucia: 我们三个是蝴蝶
Lucia: The three of us are butterflies.
Lucia: 这是诱捕器
Lucia: This is the trap.
Shure: 发蝴蝶
Shure: Release butterflies.
Shure:  要不是哎呀他们
Shure: If it weren't for them...
Jake:我还有我还有一个裤子绿色的
Jake: I still have another pair of green pants.
Shure:  一二三
Shure: One, two, three.
Shure:  那实在不行咱们串到周三某一天开吧
Shure: If it really doesn't work, let's move it to a Wednesday.
Shure:  下周三下周三是几号
Shure: What date is next Wednesday?
Shure: 下周三是24
Shure: Next Wednesday is the 24th.
Shure:  那咱们下周一排一天
Shure: Then let's schedule it for next Monday.
Lucia: 还有一个中性的
Lucia: There's also a neutral one.
Alice:还有男蝴蝶就是跟我穿那个不一样的
Alice: And the male butterfly is different from what I'm wearing.
Shure:  或者下周三
Shure: Or next Wednesday.
Alice:就平时看见EFP竟然是个女的形象
Alice: Usually, we see EFP in a female image.
其他人：手链掉了之后狂发语音开始
Others: After losing the bracelet, they started sending a lot of voice messages.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  工作有一点
Shure: Just a bit of work.
其他人：啊留恋是吧
Others: Oh, you're feeling nostalgic?
Shure:  什么留恋
Shure: What nostalgia?
Shure:  没有那是我给我女朋友起的备注
Shure: No, that's just a note I made for my girlfriend.
Shure:  之前说她像刘恋
Shure: I once said she looks like Liu Lian.
其他人：是有点像
Others: She does look a bit like her.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia:  啊对对
Lucia: Oh yeah, right.
Katrina: 前两天测MB
Katrina: I took the MB test a couple of days ago.
Katrina: 发现我变成s人了
Katrina: And found out I turned into an "S" person.
Shure:  然后她有点时候
Shure: And sometimes she...
其他人：啊ESMP吗
Others: Ah, ESMP?
Katrina: ESTJ
Katrina: ESTJ.
Alice:ESTJ是尺节尺子
Alice: ESTJ, that's the ruler type.
Lucia:  ESTJ我朋友里好像都没有ESTJ
Lucia: I don't think any of my friends are ESTJ.
Katrina: 他上次不是说没有s吗
Katrina: Didn't he say he wasn't an "S" last time?
Katrina: 因为因为我是这两天才变成了s
Katrina: Because, because I just became an "S" these past couple of days.
Shure:  我靠我靠可以啊
Shure: Whoa, whoa, impressive.
Katrina: 不知道为什么变成
Katrina: I don't know why I changed.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Whoa.
Katrina: 我本来是ENT
Katrina: I used to be ENT.
Katrina: 结果变成了e
Katrina: Then I turned into E...
Katrina: 那就是唯一一个s人了是不是
Katrina: So I'm the only "S" person, right?
Shure:  天哪
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake: 啊你怎么突然变成了s
Jake: How did you suddenly become an "S"?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 就是好像在就是来北京前一天测的
Katrina: It was like, I took the test the day before coming to Beijing.
Shure:  啊你是看浪姐的时候磕他们两个
Shure: Oh, did you start shipping them when watching "Sisters Who Make Waves"?
Jake: 来北京突然变异了
Jake: You mutated as soon as you came to Beijing.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 果然是变异
Jake: Definitely a mutation.
其他人：我不磕他们两个我磕的是另外一对然后
Others: I don't ship them, I ship another pair, and then...
Jake: 一直在变异
Jake: Always mutating.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia:  就是本来你说紫藤和那个谢斌竹
Lucia: You said originally it was Zitong and Xie Binzhu.
其他人：她单独我比较喜欢
Others: I like her individually more.
Shure:  刘恋跟薛凯琪
Lucia:  都是换了
Lucia: They all changed.
Lucia:  换了发型
Lucia: Changed their hairstyles.
Jake: 噢真的吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia:  然后然后现在那个
Lucia: And then now, um...
Jake: 噢OK OK OK
Jake: Oh, OK OK OK
Lucia:  哈哈又有人从n变成了s
Lucia: Haha, someone went from N to S again
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Katrina: 对我刚开始没嗯
Katrina: Yeah, at first I didn't, um...
Lucia:  雨轩真的从n变成了s吗
Lucia: Did Yuxuan really go from N to S?
Jake: 你们有一个人从屁变成借我导致
Jake: One of you went from P to borrowing me, causing...
Jake: 能理解哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: I get it, hahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Lucia:  实话说我这两天已经有点想要变成g
Lucia: Honestly, I've been thinking about becoming G these past few days
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：但我现场看刘恋不看赵梦是看到对多的刘恋没怎么看到过
Tasha:  因为整个组织的无纪律性
Tasha: Because the whole organization is undisciplined
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia:  不过也挺好的
Lucia: But it's pretty good
Shure:  你去看裤子的演唱会
Shure: You went to see the Pants concert
Lucia:  我喜欢一些随机事件发生
Lucia: I like when random things happen
其他人：嗯
Others: Mm
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god
Lucia:  就本质上还是很p
Lucia: It's basically very P
其他人：看音乐节吗音乐节比较多一点
Others: Do you watch music festivals? There's more of that
Jake: 这个太这个太P了
Jake: This is too P, it's too P
Jake: 这个太p了
Jake: This is too P
Katrina: 走哪呢
Katrina: Where are we going?
Katrina: 这能这能过去吗
Katrina: Can we pass through here?
Lucia:  我觉得我大部分的朋友都是NP
Lucia: I think most of my friends are NP
Alice:确实
Alice: True
Katrina: 我朋友是INFP
Katrina: My friend is INFP
Katrina: 他说我每一个字母都非常的冷漠
Katrina: He says every letter of mine is very cold
Katrina: 哈哈他说EST这个
Katrina: Haha, he says EST is...
Alice:看到就想逃
Alice: Makes you want to run away
Lucia:  好像在我的小伙伴里就关系很好
Lucia: It seems like among my friends, those close ones
Lucia:  就是好到大家互相
Lucia: Are really close, like everyone...
Lucia:  这种MBTA类型的里面好像没有
Lucia: In this MBTI type, there aren't...
Katrina: 但是我闺蜜全是哀人好神奇
Katrina: But all my besties are I types, so strange
其他人：那就是你一个E人把他们
Others: So you, an E type, bring them...
Katrina: 就是我跟哀人能建立那种长期的关系
Katrina: I can build long-term relationships with I types
其他人：其实他们很喜欢那写一对一的交流
Others: Actually, they really like those one-on-one interactions
其他人：然后呢
Others: And then?
Shure:  我也是哀人
Shure: I'm also a sad person.
Katrina: 真的假
Katrina: Really? No way.
Shure:  因为你刚才说你说完这个我感觉我更像哀人
Shure: Because after you said that, I feel even more like a sad person.
Katrina: 我之前一直不明白NAS有啥区别
Katrina: I never understood the difference with NAS.
Katrina: 我之前一直是ENTJ呃
Katrina: I was always an ENTJ before.
Katrina: 分手那会儿变成了ENFJ
Katrina: After the breakup, I became an ENFJ.
Katrina: 然后变成感性了
Katrina: Then I became emotional.
Katrina: 然后后来走出来以后又变成ENTJ
Katrina: But after getting over it, I became an ENTJ again.
Katrina: 然后现在变成ESTJ
Katrina: And now I'm an ESTJ.
Katrina: 就是现n是长远
Katrina: So "N" is for long-term vision.
Katrina: s是现务实
Katrina: "S" is for being practical.
其他人：N可能是抽象聊天就喜欢聊一些梦想什么星空
Others: "N" might mean liking abstract conversations, like talking about dreams and the stars.
Shure:  想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: I want to talk about the universe and the sky with you.
其他人：往哪边
Others: Which way?
Katrina: 不知道往哪边
Katrina: I don't know which way.
其他人：分道扬镳了是吗
Others: Are we splitting up?
Shure:  往那边走
Shure: Let's go that way.
Katrina: 反正大体方向应该是往这吧
Katrina: Anyway, the general direction should be this way.
Lucia:  我随机选一条路吧哈哈
Lucia: I'll just pick a random path, haha.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake: 好好我们听j的
Jake: Okay, okay, let's follow "J".
Katrina: 好的
Katrina: Okay.
Shure:  来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure:  石头剪刀布J
Shure: Rock-paper-scissors, J.
Shure:  你赢了就往那边走好吧
Shure: If you win, we go that way, okay?
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia:  啊我们要分分组走了吗哦OK OK
Lucia: Ah, are we splitting into groups now? Oh, okay, okay.
Shure:  算了走吧
Shure: Never mind, let's go.
Jake: 没有他们在选路
Jake: No, they are picking a path.
Jake: 他们做历史的抉择
Jake: They are making a historical decision.
Lucia:  历史的抉择
Lucia: A historical decision.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice:历史的分岔路口
Alice: A historical crossroads.
Jake: 走左还是走右啊
Jake: Left or right?
Lucia:  啊哈你这有别的意思吗
Lucia: Haha, do you mean something else?
Jake: 没有别的意思哈哈哈
Jake: No other meaning, hahaha.
Lucia:  哈哈这段是不是要剪掉啊
Lucia: Haha, should we cut this part out?
Shure:  你不要瞎问
Shure: Don't ask silly questions.
Lucia:  这不要瞎问
Lucia: Don't ask random questions.
Tasha:  什么叫左左还是左右
Tasha: What do you mean by "left-left" or "left-right"?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure:  我们这些放到文本里都是没有问题的
Shure: When we put these in the text, it's fine.
Lucia:  对对确实确实
Lucia: Yes, yes, indeed.
Jake: 没有什么意思就是左
Jake: It doesn't mean anything, just "left".
Jake: 向左转还是向右转
Jake: Turn left or turn right.
Shure:  你是在认真的发问是吗
Shure: Are you seriously asking?
Tasha:  对我我没有听懂这个梗
Tasha: Yeah, I didn't get the joke.
Lucia:  其实也没事
Lucia: Actually, it's no big deal.
Shure:  不行
Shure: No, it's not okay.
Lucia:  这是现在的那个啥也很常见的
Lucia: This is very common nowadays.
Shure:  是
Shure: Yes.
Lucia:  也不一定非得有什么
Lucia: It doesn't necessarily have to mean anything.
Shure:  在那个时期
Shure: In that period.
Jake: 在那个时期可能就剪刀石头布
Jake: In that period, it could just be rock-paper-scissors.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:  还有别的隐喻吗
Tasha: Are there any other metaphors?
Lucia:  一定要再多加两两多补两刀吗
Lucia: Do we have to add two more stabs?
Shure:  左右吗
Shure: Left and right?
Tasha:  左右
Tasha: Left and right.
Shure:  那个时期
Shure: That period.
Jake: 就是就是一分钟之前
Jake: Just a minute ago.
Lucia:  对对对对是这样的
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's how it is.
Jake: 没有别的意思
Jake: No other meaning.
Jake: 对对因为很难选嘛
Jake: Yeah, because it's hard to choose.
Shure:  这个等停止录了再跟你说
Shure: I'll tell you after we stop recording.
Tasha:  好科普一下
Tasha: Okay, explain it to me.
Jake: 你在录吧
Jake: Are you recording?
Jake: 我看看你的灯
Jake: Let me check your light.
Shure:  我在录我能看到
Shure: I'm recording, I can see it.
Jake: 哦确实外面看不太清
Jake: Oh, it's hard to see from the outside.
Jake: 但是得看一看好的
Jake: But you should check it.
Tasha:  都在录
Tasha: We're all recording.
Shure:  我斜斜的往上看一眼就能看到
Shure: I can see it if I glance up sideways.
Alice:我这个好像红色的灯
Alice: Mine seems to have a red light.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 哦那你你看一下
Jake: Oh, then you check it.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake: 是不是快没电了还是怎么的
Jake: Is it running out of battery or what?
Katrina: 那你去重庆过没
Katrina: Have you been to Chongqing?
其他人：对对对我去过很喜欢
Others: Yeah, yeah, I've been there and I really like it.
Lucia:  亮好像是还亮着的
Lucia: The light seems to still be on.
Katrina: 我之前老去重庆
Katrina: I used to go to Chongqing a lot.
Katrina: 因为前男友在重庆
Katrina: Because my ex-boyfriend is in Chongqing.
Jake: 要不就是过热要不就是它过热
Jake: Either it's overheating or it's definitely overheating.
Katrina: 我特别喜欢重庆这城市很有意思
Katrina: I really like Chongqing, it's a very interesting city.
Jake: 它会报警
Jake: It will give an alert.
Katrina: 你你在因为因为我在很老去
Katrina: You know, because I go there often...
Katrina: 然后就不会总是打卡景点啥的嘛
Katrina: I don't always visit the tourist spots.
Alice:100%的电
Alice: 100% charged.
Katrina: 然后就走在他们那个呃
Katrina: So I just walk around their...
Jake: 100%的电你插电呢是吧
Jake: 100% charged? Are you plugging it in?
Katrina: 小道居民区啊什么
Katrina: Little alleys and residential areas and stuff.
Jake: 他插电了
Jake: He plugged it in.
Alice:因为我在一直充电
Alice: Because I've been charging it all along.
Katrina: 哎就很有就很不一样的感觉
Katrina: Yeah, it feels really different.
Katrina: 重庆
Katrina: Chongqing.
其他人：嗯是的
Others: Yeah, it does.
Katrina: 重庆比成都更有特色我觉得
Katrina: I think Chongqing has more character than Chengdu.
其他人：我看那房子坐落在山上然后高高在上
Others: I see those houses perched on the mountains, really high up.
Katrina: 嗯但那边确实不好
Katrina: Yeah, but it's really not good...
Katrina: 穿带跟的鞋容易崴脚
Katrina: Wearing heels, it's easy to sprain your ankle.
Katrina: 我姐去第一天就崴脚
Katrina: My sister sprained her ankle on the first day.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 波光粼粼唉
Katrina: The water sparkles, sigh.
Katrina: 这谁在种菜吗这是
Katrina: Who's growing vegetables here?
Alice:小蝴蝶
Alice: Little butterfly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 我也是
Katrina: Me too.
Alice:被圆了
Alice: It's been rounded.
Shure:  我靠想在上面滚一圈对
Shure: Damn, I want to roll around on it.
其他人：我刚想说
Others: I was just about to say.
Shure:  有人要滚一圈吗
Shure: Anyone want to roll around?
其他人：他要滚下去
Others: He's going to roll down.
Katrina: 滚呗
Katrina: Go ahead.
其他人：你的眼镜可那什么了还是算了吧
Others: Your glasses will... Never mind.
Shure:  算了吧
Shure: Never mind.
Jake: 算了
Jake: Never mind.
Shure:  要是不不戴着眼镜
Shure: If I wasn't wearing glasses...
Jake: 等不录的话你可以滚下去
Jake: If you don't record, you can get lost.
其他人：因为草坪可能舒服
Shure:  我说眼镜看好我我给你
Shure: I said, watch my glasses, I'll give them to you.
Shure:  表演一个大的
Shure: Let's do a big performance.
Lucia:  你把眼镜放到这录着你自己滚下去
Lucia: You put the glasses there, record yourself rolling down.
Shure:  算了别污染数据集了
Shure: Forget it, don't contaminate the dataset.
Shure:  不然的话她以为人类的行动方式有一个是滚
Shure: Otherwise, she might think one way humans move is by rolling.
Shure:  并且我们平时也会说很多滚
Shure: And we often say "roll" a lot.
Alice:请你圆润的滚开
Alice: Please roll away gracefully.
Lucia:  不是
Lucia: No.
Jake: 就是他
Jake: Exactly, him.
Lucia:  这是早早期人类撒欢的珍贵记录
Lucia: This is a precious record of early humans playing around.
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 就是从此以后就是
Jake: From now on...
Jake: 呃如果一个人想到那边
Jake: If someone thinks about going there...
Jake: 然后就会Rick man的一个滚下去的做法
Jake: They'll do it by rolling down like Rick man.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  哦确实
Shure: Oh, indeed.
Jake: 这样效率更高哈哈哈
Jake: This way it's more efficient, hahaha.
Lucia:  这是人工智障吧这是
Lucia: This is artificial stupidity, right?
Jake: 人工智障那就是
Jake: Artificial stupidity, exactly.
Shure:  因为你看咱们刚才走了一个陡坡
Shure: Because you see, we just walked up a steep slope.
Shure:  然后咱们走的时间可能就是很慢
Shure: And it took us quite a while.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  但是她现在录到了
Shure: But now she's recorded it.
Shure:  我从这到那个下坡滚下去这时间更快了
Shure: I rolled down from here to the slope much faster.
Lucia:  啊所以
Lucia: Ah, so...
Shure:  他肯定就
Shure: He'll definitely...
Lucia:  当给出的指令是计算最快路线的时候
Lucia: When given the command to calculate the fastest route...
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  就会滚
Lucia: He'll roll.
Shure:  她就以为
Shure: She'll think...
Tasha:  啊就会走这里
Tasha: Ah, she'll go here.
Tasha:  抄近路了
Tasha: Taking a shortcut.
Jake: 哎抄近道然后走的话晚上他就给我
Jake: Yeah, taking a shortcut, then at night he'll give me...
Alice:高德地图不管我能不能过去
Alice: Gaode map doesn't care if I can pass through or not.
Alice:反正他就给我一个穿墙的选项
Alice: Anyway, it just gives me an option to go through walls.
Alice:是不是也是这样的
Alice: Isn't that the case?
Shure:  有可能
Shure: Probably.
Jake: 穿墙 这不行
Jake: Passing through walls? That's not possible.
Katrina: 对这好像是北运河
Katrina: Yeah, this seems like the North Canal.
Lucia:  那个应该是他数据没及时更新
Lucia: Maybe his data didn't update in time.
Lucia:  就是他不知道哪封 上
Lucia: He doesn't know which one is closed.
Jake: 对这是不够智能
Jake: Yeah, it's not smart enough.
Jake: 就是滚下去是可以实现的
Jake: Rolling down is doable.
Jake: 穿墙是不可实现的
Jake: But passing through walls is not.
Lucia:  你怎么知道
Lucia: How do you know?
Lucia:  他不是想让你把墙砸掉啊
Lucia: He doesn't want you to break the wall, right?
Jake: 哈哈哦哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, oh hahaha.
Alice:吧管我的死活是吧哈哈哈
Alice: So you don't care about my life, huh? Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈那人家会游泳的哈哈
Katrina: Haha, but they can swim. Haha.
其他人：啊对呀
Others: Oh, right.
其他人：也构不成什么威胁
Others: It's not really a threat.
Alice:哎在这浇花很方便
Alice: Hey, it's convenient to water plants here.
Alice:直接往这一冲
Alice: Just pour it directly here.
Alice:水顺着就流下去了
Alice: The water flows down smoothly.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  这就是梯田是吗
Shure: Is this a terrace field?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  算梯形的田吗
Shure: Is it considered a trapezoidal field?
其他人：哎你知道有那种表格
Others: Hey, you know those charts.
其他人：就是什么混乱邪恶混乱中立
Others: Like chaotic evil, chaotic neutral.
其他人：然后什么什么也算梯田那种
Others: And, you know, those are also considered terraces.
Alice:水好亮
Alice: The water is so bright.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha:  波光粼粼
Tasha: The shimmering light.
Shure: 好热啊我靠
Shure: It's so hot, damn.
Jake: 来看你们表演
Jake: Let's watch your performance.
Lucia:  没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia:  就是你们刚才那个波光粼粼
Lucia: It's just that shimmering light you mentioned earlier.
Lucia:  我突然想起来昨
Lucia: It suddenly reminded me of yesterday.
Lucia:  天的成语接龙
Lucia: The idiom game we played.
Shure: 这是哪个学校的帽子
Shure: Which school's cap is this?
Alice:我先来
Alice: Let me go first.
Shure: 啊这是球队的帽子
Shure: Ah, it's a team cap.
Lucia:  对对巴萨了
Lucia: Yeah, it's from Barcelona.
Jake: 这什么球队
Jake: Which team is this?
Jake: 看一下哦
Jake: Let's take a look.
Shure: 我有一个这个的围脖
Shure: I have a scarf of this team.
Jake: 阿塞尔的
Jake: Arsenal's
Lucia:  真的在真的在
Lucia: Really, really
Lucia:  那个诺坎普买的哈哈
Lucia: Bought it at Camp Nou haha
Jake: OK
Alice:成语接龙
Alice: Chengyu relay game
Lucia:  我现在不是不是巴萨的球迷了
Lucia: I'm not a Barca fan anymore
Lucia:  也不是不是
Lucia: Not anymore
Lucia:  就是还没有到路转不是
Lucia: But not to the point of being neutral
Lucia:  也没有到粉转黑的程度
Lucia: And not to the point of being a hater
Alice:第一个为所欲为
Alice: The first one is "doing whatever you want"
Lucia:  就粉转路吧
Lucia: Just neutral
Alice:下一个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Next one hahaha
Lucia:  因为这两年管理太混乱了
Lucia: Because management has been a mess these past two years
Alice:成语接龙
Alice: Chengyu relay game
Shure: 维他命C
Shure: Vitamin C
Alice:为所欲为
Alice: "Doing whatever you want"
Lucia:  我正在试图找一个新球队
Lucia: I'm trying to find a new team
Shure:  维他命 c
Shure: Vitamin C
Lucia:  现在目前的备选是阿森纳
Lucia: Currently considering Arsenal
Jake: 阿森纳大炮
Jake: Arsenal's cannon
Katrina: 一开头只能想到脏话
Katrina: The first thing that comes to mind is a curse word
Katrina: 不好意思
Katrina: Sorry
Alice:维他命c也能是成语吗
Alice: Can Vitamin C even be a chengyu?
Shure: C你吗啊
Shure: C you, huh?
Katrina: 呵呵CNMD
Katrina: Haha, CNMD
Lucia:  everywhere
Lucia: Everywhere
Lucia:  啊 对 像
Lucia: Ah, yes, like
Katrina: cos
Katrina: Cos
Shure:  他可能去打猎吧
Shure: Maybe he's out hunting
Katrina: 好帅
Katrina: So cool
Shure:  给AI看看人类早期打猎
Shure: Showing AI how early humans hunted
Shure:  珍贵影像
Shure: Precious footage
其他人：我感觉要走出去了
Others: I feel like we're going outside
其他人：不知道是哪
Others: Not sure where
Shure: （歌词）我爱你
Shure: (Singing) I love you
Shure: （歌词）可惜关系变成没关系
Shure: (Singing) But it's a pity our relationship turned into nothing
Jake: 但前面是有卖东西的地方吗
Jake: But is there a place to buy things up ahead?
Tasha:  社区便利店
Tasha: Community convenience store
Jake: 像吗这个像吗
Jake: Does it look like it?
Jake: 社区便利店确实是
Jake: It really is a community convenience store
Shure:  但是他有没有可能在墙那里面呢
Shure: But is it possible he's inside the wall?
Tasha:  让他伸出来
Tasha: Let him stick it out.
Tasha:  爷爷给我一瓶水
Tasha: Grandpa, give me a bottle of water.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 手机连成一串
Jake: Connect the phones together.
Jake: 谢谢您哎呀
Jake: Thank you, oh dear.
其他人：哎这个包包还在你带出来了吗
Others: Hey, is that bag still with you, did you bring it out?
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yes, this one.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Jake: 对啊得有一个包嘛
Jake: Yes, we need a bag.
Shure:  这包好沉啊
Shure: This bag is so heavy.
Lucia:  哈哈哈我不会说出去的
Lucia: Haha, I won't tell anyone.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia:  快乐吃瓜哈哈
Lucia: Happy gossiping, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 长见识了
Katrina: Learned something new.
Alice:什么鬼
Alice: What the heck?
Shure:  我真快渴死了
Shure: I'm really dying of thirst.
其他人：我也是啊
Others: Me too.
Shure:   我看到那个水我现在就想来一口
Shure: When I see that water, I just want to take a sip.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:  没错过是吧
Lucia: Haven't missed it, right?
Katrina: 30度
Katrina: 30 degrees.
其他人：30度
Others: 30 degrees.
Shure:  多少
Shure: How much?
Katrina: 现在30度
Katrina: It's 30 degrees now.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Katrina: 我还带了加绒卫衣呢
Katrina: I even brought a fleece sweatshirt.
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
其他人：我上周还在穿黑羽绒服
Others: I was still wearing a black down jacket last week.
Jake: 这确实出不去对吧
Jake: You really can't go out, right?
Tasha:  便民空间
Tasha: Convenience space.
Tasha:  里面没有便民超市
Tasha: There's no convenience store inside.
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 那这个空间是干嘛的呢
Jake: So what's this space for?
Tasha:  类似于那种社区空间
Tasha: It's like a community space.
Jake: 打麻将用的
Jake: For playing Mahjong.
Shure:  哦应该是
Shure: Oh, it should be.
Lucia:  还有乒乓球估计
Lucia: There should be ping pong balls too.
Jake: 那这也
Jake: Well, this too...
Tasha:  哎但这有卖水的门口
Tasha: Hey, but there's a water seller at the entrance.
Katrina: 那好像能出去
Katrina: It seems like we can go out.
Katrina: 出去就过来
Katrina: Just go out and come back.
Katrina: 应该这种修的这种道都会用
Katrina: Roads like this are usually used.
Lucia:  有被晒到
Lucia: Getting sunburned.
其他人：现在我们算是野餐完毕了
Others: Now we can say the picnic is over.
Shure:  算
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  我们的野餐
Shure: Our picnic.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  我们的野餐就是刚刚在在那个栏杆上
Shure: Our picnic was just on that railing.
Lucia:  其实已经吃掉一盒了
Lucia: Actually, we already finished a box.
Shure:  然后吃披萨
Shure: And then we ate pizza.
Jake: 跟鱼一起吃披萨对
Jake: Ate pizza with fish, right.
Shure:  对好爆掉一个手串
Shure: Yeah, and broke a bracelet.
Tasha:  什么生态共享
Tasha: Some kind of ecological sharing.
Shure:  献祭他
Shure: Sacrifice it.
Lucia:  啊他说他在说我们的野餐计划
Lucia: Ah, he's talking about our picnic plan.
Lucia:  就是刚才和鱼一起
Lucia: It was just with the fish earlier.
Jake: 还有第二餐
Jake: There's a second meal.
Jake: 其实我们还有几个披萨
Jake: Actually, we have a few more pizzas.
Lucia:  这次喂谁呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Who are we feeding this time? Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们还有一盒披萨
Jake: Hahaha, we still have a box of pizza.
Katrina: 为人吧
Katrina: For people, right?
Katrina: 可以留当晚饭了
Katrina: We can save it for dinner.
其他人：这盒现在都一样的那个彩椒披萨
Others: This box now has the same bell pepper pizza.
Shure:  确实你快决定一下
Shure: Indeed, make a decision quickly.
Lucia:  可是这里没有那个
Lucia: But there's no...
Tasha:  好像是羊肉披萨
Tasha: Seems like it's lamb pizza.
Katrina: 现在小龙虾还挺好吃
Katrina: The crayfish is quite tasty now.
Lucia:  没有那个海鸥耶
Lucia: There's no seagull here.
Katrina: 海鸥
Katrina: Seagull.
Jake: 北京竟然没有海鸥
Jake: There's no seagull in Beijing.
Lucia:  北京也不靠海吧好像
Lucia: Beijing isn't near the sea, I guess.
Jake: 北京
Jake: Beijing.
Katrina: 我身上穿的就是海鸥
Katrina: I'm wearing a seagull.
Tasha:  噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Katrina: （歌词）耳朵借我
Katrina: (Lyrics) Lend me your ear.
Tasha:  又晒又热
Tasha: It's so sunny and hot.
Lucia:  不行我要两个都摘掉我就给他拿下来
Lucia: No, I want to take both off. I'll just take them off.
Katrina: 我灯还亮吗
Katrina: Are my lights still on?
Katrina: 我是不是该充电了
Katrina: Should I recharge now?
其他人：啊是亮的
Others: Yeah, they're still on.
Katrina: 我要充会电
Katrina: I need to charge for a bit.
Lucia:  我已经为了照顾这个眼镜没有戴大
Lucia: I've been wearing this headset just to take care of these glasses, haha.
Lucia:  戴了头戴耳机了哈哈
Lucia: Wearing a headset, haha.
Tasha:  已经出去了
Tasha: It's already out there.
Tasha:  都没有遇到水
Tasha: Didn't even touch the water.
Shure: （歌词）差不多也该奔赴着美好新时代
Shure: (Lyrics) It's about time to move towards a beautiful new era.
Shure: （歌词）华东是团结的主卫呀
Shure: (Lyrics) Huadong is the main guardian of unity.
Shure: （歌词）我们一起走向富强
Shure: (Lyrics) Together we stride towards prosperity.
Lucia:  我们修正一下路线
Lucia: Let's correct our route.
Tasha:  可恶路线选错了
Tasha: Darn, we chose the wrong route.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What happened?
Shure: 不行我们去超市的时候再买水
Shure: No worries, we'll buy water when we go to the supermarket.
Jake: 那可能有点这边真的没有水哈
Jake: There might be a bit of a problem, there's really no water here.
Lucia:  也可以
Lucia: That's fine too.
Jake: 这可是居民区的呀
Jake: This is a residential area, you know.
Shure: 理论上会有 要走到小区里
Shure: In theory, there should be some. We need to walk into the neighborhood.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 刚那便利店
Katrina: That convenience store earlier...
Katrina: 只能从这出去再绕回去
Katrina: We can only go out this way and circle back.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 对我们偏离路线偏离了一公里
Jake: Yeah, we deviated from the route by about a kilometer.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有关系没有关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 没有关系
Shure: It's okay.
Shure: J人带的路
Katrina: yeah
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  一定是在这年的计划中吧
Shure: It must be part of this year's plan.
Katrina: yeah是的
Katrina: Yeah, it is.
Lucia:  一定有他的道理
Lucia: There must be a reason for it.
Alice:那我们走水路吧
Alice: Let's take the water route then.
Alice:感觉那里面凉快
Alice: It feels cooler over there.
Lucia:  我们可以沿着它走
Lucia: We can walk along it.
Jake: 我们可以过个马路得了来都来了
Jake: We can cross the street, since we're already here.
Lucia:  那就我走到保利的那块地坪上去
Lucia: Then I'll walk to the concrete area by Poly.
Jake: 对面是不是也没有什么
Jake: Is there nothing on the other side too?
Jake: 还是那就走水陆会
Jake: Then let's go to the Water and Land Conference.
Jake: 还是这边阴凉一点
Jake: Or this side is a bit shadier.
Lucia:  上说太阳现在是这个方向
Lucia: The sun is in this direction right now.
Lucia:  所以可能都不是很阴凉
Lucia: So it might not be very shady anywhere.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Alice:我们不能游过去吗
Alice: Can't we just swim across?
Jake: 可以
Jake: We can.
Shure:  但眼镜不防水
Shure: But the glasses aren't waterproof.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Alice:谁会游泳呢
Alice: Who knows how to swim?
Shure: 我
Shure: I do.
Lucia:  其实我会哈哈
Lucia: Actually, I can too, haha.
Shure: 我小时候在这种野湖里面游过
Shure: I used to swim in these wild lakes when I was a kid.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  是的我现在都是靠寄生虫活着
Shure: Yeah, now I survive on parasites.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Turn back.
Jake: 回到起点
Jake: Back to the starting point.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha:  啊什么
Tasha: What do you mean, ah?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 回到起点远吗
Katrina: 要不要先买水再回到起点
Katrina: Should we buy water first before going back to the start?
Jake: 也可以水在这附近还是
Jake: We can, is there water nearby or...
Katrina: 水就刚刚那个便利店
Katrina: Water's at that convenience store we just passed.
Katrina: 只是从这绕绕出去一下
Katrina: Just loop around a bit from here.
Jake: 好那绕一圈
Jake: Okay, then let's loop around.
Jake: 再绕一圈
Jake: Another loop.
Jake: 把小区给建了
Jake: And build the community.
Shure: 但是小区我们没有那什么能进吗
Shure: But we don't have anything to get into the community, do we?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  刷脸不可以吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can't we just use facial recognition? Hahaha.
Jake: 咱就说要买水
Jake: We'll just say we need to buy water.
Jake: 光天化日之下我们能干什么
Jake: In broad daylight, what could we possibly do?
Katrina: 这应该能进去吧这边
Katrina: This should get us in, right, here?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Lucia:  拍VLOG吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's vlog it, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 草莓熊
Shure: Lotso.
Lucia:  哎呀干嘛
Lucia: Hey, what are you doing?
Alice:吓死我了
Alice: You scared me to death.
Alice:啊对不起哦
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Lucia:  对不起
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice:没有没有没有
Alice: No, no, no.
Alice:我在想事情
Alice: I was just thinking.
Alice:我在想我五一怎么回家
Alice: I was thinking about how to get home for Labor Day.
Alice:要不要回家
Alice: Should I go home or not?
Alice:你的五一安排是什么
Alice: What are your plans for Labor Day?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 但这应该有有电
Katrina: But there should be power here.
Shure: 像有的地方可是J人的计划不是从这往里走吗
Shure: In some places, isn't J's plan to go in from here?
Shure:  如果我们越来越更近
Shure: If we get closer and closer...
Katrina: 我只我只负责大大
Katrina: I'm only responsible for the big picture.
Shure:  你会感觉
Shure: You'll feel...
Shure:  就是领导呗只负责大方向
Shure: Just like a leader, only responsible for the big direction.
Katrina: 这进不去
Katrina: This won't go through.
Katrina: 只能在这看有没有买水的
Katrina: We can only see if there's someone selling water here.
Shure:  超市有的
Shure: There's some in the supermarket.
Alice:野营的人比树还多
Alice: There were more campers than trees.
Alice:我那天快被吓死了
Alice: I was scared to death that day.
其他人：你喝什么
Others: What are you drinking?
Shure:  急需一瓶脉动
Shure: I urgently need a bottle of Pulse.
Shure:  让我脉动
Shure: Get me a Pulse.
Jake: 秒啊竟然有个大超市
Jake: Wow, there's actually a big supermarket.
Shure:  你要什么
Shure: What do you want?
Alice:那你是这个结束之后先回家还是
Alice: So are you going home after this or...
Lucia:  我现在是这样想的
Lucia: This is what I'm thinking now.
Lucia:  不过我也有可能需要在北京办点事情
Lucia: But I might need to take care of some things in Beijing.
Katrina: 我喝营养快线
Katrina: I'll have a Nutritional Express.
Alice:有无怡宝有看到了
Alice: Do they have Yibao here, did you see it?
其他人：这个报销吗
Others: Is this reimbursable?
Jake: 呃可以报吧
Jake: Uh, it should be.
Alice:有人喝矿泉水吗
Alice: Is anyone drinking mineral water?
其他人：怎么付一起付还是单付
Others: How do we pay, together or separately?
Katrina: 一起
Katrina: Together.
Jake: 一起付还是单付杨老板
Jake: Together or separately, Jake?
其他人：我们一起付还是单付
Others: Are we paying together or separately?
Jake: 一起付
Jake: Together.
Shure:  一起付
Shure: Together.
Lucia:  我要这个
Lucia: I want this one.
Alice:好你要哪个
Alice: Sure, which one do you want?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 帮我选一个吧
Jake: Help me choose one.
其他人：遇事不决吃个苦咖啡
Others: When in doubt, have a bitter coffee.
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 这个就算了
Jake: Never mind about this one.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake: 我知道我可以say no
Jake: I know I can say no.
其他人：我以为西红柿呢
Others: I thought it was a tomato.
其他人：苦咖啡
Others: Bitter coffee.
其他人：重来重来
Others: Do it again, do it again.
其他人：这是我以为西红柿
Others: I thought it was a tomato.
Lucia:  我觉得值得试试东鹏特饮
Lucia: I think it's worth trying Dongpeng Special Drink.
Lucia:  困了累了喝东鹏特饮
Lucia: When you're tired, drink Dongpeng Special Drink.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：6块钱一斤是5块8毛8
Others: 6 yuan per jin or 5 yuan 8 mao 8.
Lucia:  啊哎
Lucia: Ah, hey.
Lucia:  咱们的一样啊
Lucia: We have the same one.
其他人：我以为西红柿这个这个
Others: I thought it was a tomato, this one, this one.
其他人：15一斤 8块7
Others: 15 per jin, 8 yuan 7 mao.
其他人：刚刚上西红柿要了价钱
Others: Just asked about the price of tomatoes.
其他人：哎这不对 22块5
Others: Hey, this isn't right, 22 yuan 5 mao.
Jake: 薇薇还没选
Jake: Tasha hasn't chosen yet.
其他人：静待她拿哦她没有拿这个
Others: Wait for her to take it, oh, she didn't take this one.
Lucia:  他拿了尖叫
Lucia: He took Jiao.
其他人：没事不用放报一下就行
Others: It's okay, no need to place, just report it.
其他人：几瓶
Others: How many bottles?
其他人：123456
Others: 123456.
其他人：32一共
Others: 32 in total.
Jake: 啊扫的这么快
Jake: Wow, scanned so fast.
其他人：32 35
Others: 32, 35.
Jake:  OK行
Jake: OK, that's fine.
Jake: 我怎么付你
Jake: How do I pay you?
Jake: 我扫这个行
Jake: Can I scan this?
其他人：行
Others: Sure.
其他人：开喝
Others: Let's drink.
Jake: 35
Jake: 35.
其他人：35嗯
Others: 35, okay.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 呃走
Jake: Uh, let's go.
其他人：微信收款35元
Others: Received 35 yuan on WeChat.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Katrina: 你拿我营养快线干啥
Katrina: Why did you take my Nutrient Express?
Shure:  你拿我脉动干什么
Shure: Why did you take my Mizone?
Katrina: 哈哈哈惊呆了
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm shocked.
Katrina: 你拿我营养快线
Katrina: You took my Nutrient Express.
Shure:  我说你怼我干什么
Shure: Why are you hitting me?
Katrina: 我以为我记记记错了
Katrina: I thought I remembered wrong.
Shure:  而且我还没没什么反应
Shure: And I didn't even react.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really.
Katrina: 嗯我不是拿营养快线吗
Katrina: I thought I took Nutrient Express.
Jake: 一个7新币的水
Jake: A 7 SGD water.
Jake: 哈哈哈也可以
Jake: Hahaha, that's fine too.
Katrina: 慢点慢点慢点
Katrina: Slow down, slow down.
Shure:  怎么说下一站吗
Shure: What about the next stop?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Katrina: 回到起点
Katrina: Back to the starting point.
Katrina: 下一站去哪
Katrina: Where's the next stop?
Katrina: 要不直接在这打车也行
Katrina: Or we could just take a cab from here.
Jake: 也行啊下一站去哪啊
Jake: That's fine, where's the next stop?
Shure:  我们找找个好打车的地
Shure: Let's find a place where we can get a cab.
Alice:买什么调料跟什么肉啥来着
Alice: What condiments and meat do we need to buy?
Shure:  这这应该不好打车
Shure: This place might be hard to get a cab.
Jake: 呃不好意思
Jake: Uh, sorry.
Jake: 去哪买啊
Jake: Where should we buy it?
Shure:  找一个大一点的
Shure: Let's find a bigger one.
Shure:  商超吧还是
Shure: Like a supermarket.
Alice:有没有那种什么食材
Alice: Is there any place that sells ingredients?
Alice:批发
Alice: Wholesale.
Alice:市场那种直接带串好签的不也行吗
Alice: Or a market that has ready-to-skewer stuff.
Tasha:  一旦我发起这个话题你就会很认同
Tasha: Once I bring this up, you'll really agree.
Shure:  也行
Shure: That works.
Tasha:  小蝴蝶是这样的
Tasha: That's how it is with Little Butterfly.
Alice:碳油刷子
Alice: Charcoal, oil brush.
Katrina: 菜市场
Katrina: Farmers' market.
Katrina: 大超市
Katrina: Big supermarket.
Shure:  搜一搜勾人
Shure: Search for it, it's enticing.
Tasha:  嗯很凉快
Tasha: Hmm, it's really cool.
Katrina: 这200米居然有个盒马先生
Katrina: There's actually a Hema Fresh within 200 meters.
Katrina: 200米居然只有
Katrina: Only 200 meters away.
Jake: 一定有点
Jake: There must be something.
Shure:  四四四百米
Shure: 400 meters.
Katrina: 400米有个河马先生
Katrina: There's a Hema Fresh 400 meters away.
Jake: 走吧走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Yeah, let's go.
Katrina: 去盒马是吗
Katrina: To Hema, right?
其他人：去盒马可以把晚饭解决了
Others: We can solve dinner at Hema.
Shure:  走带路
Shure: Lead the way.
Katrina: 那就盒马
Katrina: Then it's Hema.
Katrina: 直接买那个肉
Katrina: Just buy the meat.
Katrina: 然后烤肉
Katrina: And then grill it.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 还有对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Tasha:  那还回公园吗
Tasha: Are we going back to the park?
Jake: 不回了不回了吧
Jake: No, we're not going back.
Shure:  嗯吧吧布
Shure: Hmm, ba ba boo.
Katrina: 终于找到这首歌
Katrina: Finally found this song.
Katrina: 一直哼哼哼哼
Katrina: I've been humming it nonstop.
Katrina: 我刚刚不是一直哼这一句吗
Katrina: Haven't I been humming this part?
Katrina: 我说什么歌来
Katrina: I was wondering what song it is.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  给你补个差价
Shure: I'll make up the difference for you.
Lucia:  我应该打打个伞
Lucia: I should've brought an umbrella.
Lucia:  我其实带了一把伞在箱子里
Lucia: I actually have one in my suitcase.
Katrina: 北京麦当劳是真多呀
Katrina: There are so many McDonald's in Beijing.
Katrina: 感觉到处都是麦当劳
Katrina: Feels like they're everywhere.
Shure:  麦门永存
Shure: Long live McDonald's.
Shure:  从从B1
Shure: From B1.
Shure:  那应该从这下吧
Shure: We should go down from here.
Shure:  我们要不要去打电玩哈哈哈
Shure: How about we play some arcade games, haha.
Shure:  抓个娃娃
Shure: Catch a doll.
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina: 老板能不能批100经费
Katrina: Can the boss approve 100 for expenses?
Jake: 这个商场档次如何
Jake: How's the quality of this mall?
Alice:你要抓娃娃
Alice: You want to catch dolls.
Jake: 风云再起是什么
Jake: What's Fengyun Zaiqi?
Alice:呃电
Alice: Uh, electricity
Alice:不是是那种打电动的
Alice: No, I mean like playing video games
Katrina: 哎这烧烤店能不能问他买
Katrina: Hey, can we ask this BBQ place to sell it to us?
Shure:  哈哈哈不行
Shure: Hahaha, no way
Katrina: 你说我们跟您隔这么远
Katrina: You know, we're so far away from you
Katrina: 又没有竞争
Katrina: There's no competition
Katrina: 我们又不用做商业用途
Katrina: We're not using it for commercial purposes
Katrina: 卖我们吧
Katrina: Just sell it to us
Katrina: 成全一个年轻人的开心
Katrina: Make a young person happy
Shure:  我们要自己动手丰衣足食
Shure: We need to do it ourselves to be self-sufficient
Katrina: 那你穿哈我我吃
Katrina: Then you wear it, I'll eat
Shure:  我们不穿
Shure: We won't wear it
Shure:  我们去看烤片吧
Shure: Let's go check out the BBQ slices
Katrina: 烤片那肉是不是得先腌呢
Katrina: Do we need to marinate the meat first for BBQ slices?
Katrina: 我靠这炉子也要v的
Katrina: Damn, does this grill also need a V?
Katrina: 他开玩笑
Katrina: He's joking
Katrina: 噢这还不是B1啊
Katrina: Oh, this isn't even B1
Katrina: 好特卖去不去
Katrina: Hey, want to go to the sale?
Shure:  什么哪儿呢
Shure: What? Where?
Shure:  这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Jake: 哎我们先
Jake: Hey, let's first
Jake: 我我们我们先在商场里边整点活吧
Jake: Let's do some stuff in the mall first
Katrina: 便宜货
Katrina: Cheap stuff
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Jake: 先晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around first
Jake: 然后再买东西再提走对
Jake: Then we can buy stuff and take it, right?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Lucia:  可以
Lucia: Sure
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure
Shure:  我们去小米买点电电池哈哈哈
Shure: Let's go buy some batteries from Xiaomi, hahaha
Katrina: 还有好特卖呢
Katrina: There's also a sale
Lucia:  哦好特卖
Lucia: Oh, a sale
Katrina: 我最喜欢买
Katrina: I love buying
Katrina: 好特卖好特卖好特卖好特卖
Katrina: Sale, sale, sale, sale
Shure:  哦我们出发的时候忘看这个
Shure: Oh, we forgot to check this when we left
Jake: 对没看这个东西对好
Jake: Yeah, didn't check this, right
Jake: 3:47 行
Jake: 3:47, okay
Shure:  进去看看
Shure: Let's go in and take a look
Alice:你抓娃娃厉害吗
Alice: Are you good at claw machines?
Lucia:  3都3块钱了
Lucia: It's already 3 bucks each
Lucia:  北京已经这个行情了吗
Lucia: Has the market in Beijing already come to this?
Tasha:  觉得在团购上买会不会便宜
Tasha: Do you think it would be cheaper to buy in a group purchase?
Jake: 100个币是什么意思
Jake: What does 100 coins mean?
Jake: 100个币抓几次
Jake: How many tries for 100 coins?
Shure: 我看一眼
Shure: Let me take a look.
Shure:  3个币左右
Shure: About 3 coins per try.
Jake: 那我100个币你们你们自由分配
Jake: Then I'll give you guys 100 coins to distribute freely.
Katrina: 好吧那就微信购
Katrina: Alright, let's buy it on WeChat.
Jake: 好吧好行
Jake: Okay, sounds good.
Shure:   好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  呼呼
Shure: Phew.
Katrina: 就扫这个嘛那89
Katrina: Just scan this, right? It's 89.
Shure:  扫
Shure: Scan.
Katrina: 耶老板万岁哈哈
Katrina: Yay, long live the boss, haha.
Shure:  若每人夸一句杨哥好帅
Shure: Everyone should praise Jake and say he's handsome.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Katrina: 付款的瞬间最帅
Katrina: He's the most handsome when making a payment.
Alice:有那个大众点评哎
Alice: There's that public review site.
Alice:不对那叫啥来着团购
Alice: No wait, what's it called, group buying?
Jake: 100个币889是吧
Jake: 100 coins for 889, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha:  这个会不会便宜一些
Tasha: Wouldn't this be a bit cheaper?
Shure:  应该差不多耶
Shure: It should be about the same.
Jake: 就这样吧
Jake: Let's go with it.
Katrina: 这应该是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Jake: 够还行
Jake: It's good enough.
Katrina: 抖音套餐
Katrina: A TikTok package.
Katrina: 嗯然后再哇
Katrina: Hmm, and then wow.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Jake: 哦不然还得剪是吧
Jake: Oh, otherwise we have to cut it, right?
Jake: 又是一个离谱的数据
Jake: Another absurd number.
Katrina: 这多少
Katrina: How much is this?
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina: 84 他这89
Katrina: 84, but he's 89.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 应该差不多吧
Katrina: Should be about right.
Jake: 他动了
Jake: He moved.
Shure:  啊你需要点一下对
Shure: Ah, you need to click that, right.
其他人：哦对
Others: Oh, right.
Shure: 呜呜呜呜
Shure: Woo woo woo woo.
Katrina: 来吧
Shure:  来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:一人抓两把得了
Alice: How about we each grab two?
Katrina: 抓娃娃去
Katrina: Let's go catch some dolls.
Lucia:  是多少个啊
Lucia: How many are there?
Katrina: 你会抓娃娃吗
Katrina: Do you know how to catch dolls?
Shure:  开玩笑高玩好吗
Shure: Are you kidding? I'm a pro.
Jake: 我我们我们也抓去
Jake: We, we, let's go catch some too.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们也抓吧
Jake: Hahaha, let's go catch some too.
Katrina: 看有什么好看一点
Katrina: See if there's anything nice.
Shure:  抓小的吧
Shure: Let's catch the small ones.
Shure:  大的好像难抓一些
Shure: The big ones seem harder to catch.
Katrina: 这好丑啊
Katrina: This one's so ugly.
Shure:  还有这个角角肯定好抓
Shure: This corner here should be easy to catch.
Alice:乾坤未定
Alice: The outcome is still uncertain.
Shure:  你我皆是牛马
Shure: We're all just working hard.
Alice:牛马
Alice: Just working hard.
Jake: 这是浪费了我一个币子是吧
Jake: Did I just waste a token?
Shure:  牛马
Shure: Just working hard.
Jake: 哈哈哈那那边有那个架子鼓
Jake: Hahaha, there's a drum set over there.
Alice:三个吧
Alice: Three, right?
Shure:  啊有吗
Shure: Oh, really?
Lucia:  那边有架子鼓
Lucia: There's a drum set over there.
Lucia:  你要不要玩一下
Lucia: Do you want to play it?
Jake: 围观你打一圈呗
Jake: Let's watch you play a round.
Shure:  来一波吧
Shure: Let's have a go.
Jake: 那边
Jake: Over there.
Shure:  在哪
Shure: Where is it?
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  这也是难得素材了
Shure: This is some rare footage.
Jake: 这行吗这设备够灵玩吗
Jake: Will this work? Is the equipment good enough?
Shure:  可以可以可以可以
Shure: Yes, yes, yes, it is.
Shure:  够了够了
Shure: It's enough.
Jake: 可以是吧
Jake: It's good, right?
Jake: 等会我把大家都叫过来
Jake: Hold on, I'll call everyone over.
Jake: 你先等会
Jake: Wait a moment.
Shure:  再来再来一个
Shure: Let's do one more.
Shure:  币老板哎好
Shure: Token boss, hey, good.
Alice:给你拍个背面照可以吗
Alice: Can I take a photo of your back?
Shure:  反正他有好几次机会应该
Shure: Anyway, he had several chances.
Alice:好那我录着你哈哈
Alice: Alright, I'll record you, haha.
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  4个币子
Shure: 4 coins.
Jake: 4个币的
Jake: 4 coins?
Shure:  好像能打3首吧应该
Shure: I think you can play 3 songs with it.
Shure:  这个很赚的
Shure: It's quite a bargain.
Jake: 四四个壁子
Jake: Four coins.
Jake: 你要水平高是不是可以连打
Jake: If you're good, can you keep playing?
Shure:  好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it.
Jake: 不知道啊来
Jake: Not sure, let's try.
Jake: 啊给投过了啊行
Jake: Ah, it went through, alright.
Alice:投过了投过了
Alice: It went through, it went through.
Katrina: 哎呦表演才艺了
Katrina: Oh wow, showing off your skills.
Shure:  啊太丢人了
Shure: Ah, that was so embarrassing.
Shure:  game over 了
Shure: Game over.
Shure:  我靠哈哈哈
Shure: Damn, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈记录在案
Jake: Hahahahahaha, it's recorded.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake: 首席首席鼓
Jake: Chief drummer.
Shure:  不行不行哈哈哈
Shure: No way, no way, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.